foreign
this week the Washington Post published
an article headlined women said
coronavirus shots affect periods new
study shows they're right
sub headline a coronavirus vaccination
can change the timing of when you get
your period according to research for
most people the effect was temporary
my first reaction to this was and I
apologize some of you don't like it when
I swear and some of you like it a lot
when I swear but you don't [ __ ] say
Guapo like yeah yes we know and yes
there are a lot of us who were yelled at
and told that we were anti-vaxxers and
far worse for suggesting that people
were actually experiencing real effects
from an experimental treatment so yeah
good on you you're a little bit late
you're actually a lot bit late
so there's a news release on the study
from NIH which goes into a little bit
more detail and then of course his
original research which I'm going to
read you a few things from it's an
Edelman in all paper and um
uh bmj medicine called association
between menstrual cycle length and
covid-19 vaccination Global
retrospective cohort study of
prospectively collected data
[Music]
so
I guess let's do it this way
we wanted to no no I need a pen all
right this one doesn't work
um
the yeah let's do it this way I'm going
to read you a couple paragraphs from the
wapo piece The Washington Post piece
Allison Edelman a professor of
Obstetrics and Gynecology Oregon Health
and Science University based in our
former hometown of Portland Oregon
Allison Edelman who led the study said
that for most people the effects were
temporary lasting for one cycle before
returning to normal she said there were
no indications that the period side
effects had any impact on fertility
now we can give people information about
possibly what to expect with menstrual
cycles Edelman said so I hope that's
overall really reassuring to individuals
well no actually it's not and here's
part of why
um the study this is literally from the
abstract of the study analyze data on
quote at least three consecutive Cycles
before vaccination and at least one
cycle after
one
one cycle after vaccination and they
looked at a lot of people you know they
studied a lot of women sorry it was all
women but
the idea that you can tell anything
about long-term effects
um or impact on fertility on the basis
of a study that looked at
least but actually usually exactly three
Cycles before and one cycle after
vaccination
on what basis is she making these claims
and those claims that she's making is
the lead author on this study are now
going to be the ones that are repeated
and now are going to be the basis for
the you know PolitiFact and the fact
Checker organizations who come after
People Like Us who say actually no that
research can't say anything about
long-term effects or effects on
fertility it simply can't did you read
the study
and the fact is the fact Checkers at
these places aren't scientists they have
no ability and apparently interest in
actually reading the research on which
they are supposedly fact checking and
here we have the lead author on the
paper making egregiously misleading and
frankly just flat out wrong statements
to Washington Post which of course is
going to be the thing that people see
well and
that quote the idea that upon
discovering that indeed these effects
that many of us have talked about are
real that the proper response to that is
for people to be reassured rather than
for the safety apparatus to become
alarmed and say well all right given
that these effects are real and they
shouldn't be happening because these
things aren't supposed to be showing up
in your reproductive apparatus at all
yeah right so these that there's any
signal at all here is a story right it
is a story and the right response is how
does that change the cost benefit
analysis for any individual who might be
taking these things the answer is not oh
well in our study it turned out to be
short term because that's all we studied
right and therefore people should be
reassured I hope this will cause people
to be reassured there is nothing what
are you are you a scientist or are you
in fact someone who's just trying to
change people's minds right the point is
this is this is the sound of the
scientific apparatus being used to
rationalize irrational and dangerous
Behavior right you've got a safety
signal here and the response is oh
it isn't the safety signal is no worse
than could be found in our short-term
study therefore people it it's the
absence of evidence is no is not
evidence of absence right there is no
long-term aspect of the study published
here and so the point is they're saying
well there's no evidence of a long-term
effect well it wasn't a long-term study
here we have actually in the paper
conclusions conclusions of the as
written into the abstract quote covid-19
vaccination is associated with a small
and likely to be temporary change in
menstrual cycle length but no change in
mensi's length likely to be on the basis
of nothing in the paper that has no
place in this paper at all in the
abstract in the conclusions anywhere
where is that likely to be come from
because they want it to be that is Hope
pretending to be science and that hope
then lives in apparently the lead
authors had sufficient that she says to
The Washington Post when they come to
her she'll she repeats the hope as if it
is the science guess what hope isn't the
same as science this is not how science
works so either this is a case of
pharmaceutical idea laundering right
where they take a pharmaceutical uh
talking point and they launder it
through a scientific process so that it
appears to be uh scientific in some way
or this person actually believes they've
engaged in science themselves and it is
a case of some kind of brain laundering
right that their mind I don't see any
reason the paper it's the research that
was done yeah
if you ignore the editorializing in the
text of the paper itself and certainly
the editorializing that is happening
extra paper like outside of the paper
the the actual design of the experiment
seems to be like this the science in so
far as it said something narrow and true
seems fine so I don't I don't think we
want to say oh yeah was she even doing
science like no no no no no no I don't
agree with that because it'd be one
thing if the people who did the study
had done the study legitimately and then
someone else scientific was commenting
on it with this sort of absurd
conclusion but if it's in the paper
itself right then the point is the paper
is a is a scientific process the
scientific method may be narrowly
applied to the experiment that was done
but the extrapolating only so far as the
evidence allows you to right right but I
didn't say this paper is a good example
of scientific research I said I think
that from what I can see the actual
research that was done although it is
not accurately portrayed in this paper
was potentially good that is what I said
well
I
I don't see it that way because
because the degree of extrapolation is
inherent to the scientific process and
so if that part is bad so that leaves
you suspect as to what else happened
that isn't visible in what we can see no
I would just say
first of all if you were to go back
through every
terrible wrong paper and say well the
work itself does was this a valid
experiment right you would find many
valid experiments that just didn't
establish the thing that the paper
claimed they'd established so yeah I'm
saying to the extent that you have
presented a piece of work and the piece
of work is
here's the data we collected and here's
what it implies based on the fact that
we had or did not have a pre-existing
hypothesis and these are the things that
showed up
Etc right the point is you either did
that job writer you didn't and to the
extent that you ran an experiment that
might be valid that embedded in some
paper but not the paper you wrote that's
a pretty thin defense okay
um
one more thing on this story
back to the Washington Post piece
later in the same article I'll just read
these two short paragraphs
other research has suggested that the
vaccines against the code vaccines have
a variety of effects on periods a survey
published last fall collected
information about periods and vaccines
from 160 000 people including
transgender and post-menopausal people
and found that thousands reported
heavier bleeding than usual or
breakthrough bleeding
while these observations aren't
necessarily medically alarming Catherine
Lee an assistant professor at Tulane
University who led the survey said the
information is important to help trans
men plan for additional support if
menstruating causes gender dysphoria and
also to help people make decisions about
stocking up on tampons and pads
so the first mainstream media
acknowledgment that all those women who
were saying that their periods were
affected by the coveted vaccines and who
are now worried about fertility issues
and such and frankly no one has done
anything to allay those concerns the
first mainstream media article to talk
about this at all somehow manages to
talk about trans men
but what is going on here how how are we
constantly coming back to a fringe
activist population when there is
actually half of the world who is at
risk from these experimental treatments
and here we are being concerned about
gender dysphoria and trans men and what
is going on it's it's worse than that
because
because it's got to be the title of this
episode it's worse than that they have
created the entire problem if you simply
didn't [ __ ] up the definition of women
then those women who happen to be trans
men would be covered by this without
having to specifically say anything
right the point is
there is something called a woman right
it has a biological definition that
isn't difficult it allows you to
extrapolate from a paper without a
problem and the only reason that there
is any argument for breaking out trans
men as victims of this is that you you
scuttled that definition for your own
political purposes it it's frankly
insane
and maybe that's the point it's more
it's more it's insane and this and this
is more
again of
the
there are a lot of sex-specific effects
of covid and the vaccines right we know
this the myoin pericarditis
uh that has been finally begun to be
acknowledged uh that is uh more of a
risk for young people is specifically
more of a risk for young men
for adolescent boys and young men
and uh early on we were hearing uh and I
actually just haven't seen the stats
recently but I assume it's still true
that all else being equal covet is more
likely to go bad for you if you're male
than if you're female if you know
controlling for all of the other
demographic truths about yourself
and so here we have one of the places
and you know of course there are all
those insane papers uh insane articles
early on about how even though men were
dying more code was harder on women
remember this
wow you're really really working hard
there but he's only hard on you at first
but here's what you've done it it
becomes it's all downhill yeah now that
now they're lazy again right those men
not doing their work not doing their
fair share of cleanup after they die
um but now we have fertility effects and
you know I don't know there may be
fertility effects for men too I haven't
we haven't been hearing about those
um so much
um but there have been Lots there has
been lots of talk about uh menstrual
effects which of course has the
potential to to be a fertility effect in
women and here we have some research
that may or may not actually be you know
bold enough to have actually seen this
and the Washington Post can't even talk
about women for one article
it it it has to go into trans activism
sophistry ideology
it would not would not allowed to just
talk about fertility effects for women
even though that would fully include
trans men yeah you didn't you didn't
need you didn't do that damn thing they
were fully included in that discussion
if you just simply didn't do a thing but
but no
it has to be the focus
[Music]